rires mais c'est à dire le problème
c'est que cette réforme est faite pour
faire baisser le pouvoir d'achat des
français
[Musique]
puis dix mois le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
28' bien rentré que les dépenses
publiques de retraite qui sont
aujourd'hui de 13,8 pour cent du pib
vont baisser jusqu'en 2050 jusqu'à 12
d'appeler 9% du pib puis ensuite sans
doute encore moins et et cette baisse
globale des dépenses alors que le nombre
de retraités va forcément augmenter en
raison des paramètres démographiques et
bien ça implique forcément une baisse
moyenne des pensions
tout le problème est comment on organise
cette baisse des pensions
et c'est là je vous dis que la précarité
de l'emploi va être une justification
pour donner le moins aux gens y compris
d'ailleurs cette retraite minimale à 85%
du smic il vient en fait elle ne sera
acquise que après une carrière complète
c'est si on a pas qu'à complète et bien
on n'aura pas les 85% du smic alors la
donne et du gouvernement c'est de dire
bon on va pas prendre simplement les
salaires puisque les salaires ce n'est
qu'une partie des revenus d'activité et
on a aussi les traitements des
fonctionnaires on a aussi l'auto
entrepreneur et c'est donc on va prendre
l'ensemble un médiateur qui représente
l'ensemble des revenus d'activité alors
le problème c'est que comme vous l'avez
dit cette année leader n'existe pas
d'ailleurs il va être difficile à mettre
en oeuvre
on n'a pas et donc le construire et qui
va prendre en compte des revenus qui
sont pas toujours simples à trouver
notamment les revenus d'entrepreneurs
l'intérêt pour le gouvernement c'est que
de fait l'évolution des salaires et plus
élevé que l'évolution des traitements
des fonctionnaires et aussi de l'emploi
souvent précarisés des auto
entrepreneurs
donc ça va faire évidemment ce
changement de passer de 2 des revenus du
solde des revenus les salaires au revenu
total d'activité et bien va faire de
fait baisser la valeur du point l'autre
élément qui est évidemment au coeur de
la réforme c'est là qu'il est question
les mesures d'âge notamment le fait que
on prévoit pas rallonger cette tâche
d'équilibrer va être amené à évoluer à
augmenter par conséquent ce qui va se
passer les carrières vont donc
s'allonger et dans le cadre de la
réforme qui est proposé tout euro cotisé
donnant droit à sa vente de points et
donc de retraite plus la carrière va
s'allonger
plus on va avoir des carrières qui sont
précarisées qui seront trouvées caron
des périodes de chômage d'une activité
et autres le niveau des pensions les
niveaux 2.1 qui va forcément baisser
mais sait on va pas forcément jouer sur
la valeur du point qui va rester la même
on va jouer sur le fait que et bien
les carrières vont s'allonger devant
devenir vont voir se multiplier des
trous ainsi qu'à des gardes d'inactivité
qui va de fait faire baisser le nombre
de points auxquels on n'a pas droit
[Musique]